what's going on a reject nation Greg
Alba here I just woke up roll out of bed
to discover that the Black Panther
trailer has dropped I think it's the
official trailer why talk anymore Greg
shut up let's talk about Wakanda
[Music]
[Music]
I looked at music in these trailers man
[Music]
my new handshake
[Music]
sweet
oh snap
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Doh doh-doh okay so of course being a
concrete movie we're gonna get a lot of
the cool visual image read a lot of the
cool styles out of the cool action and
that all looks super super duper badass
for sure in terms of like the first
parts of this trailer
when T'Challa is talking with some of
his people you're getting some hints at
what I feel like the movie will be a
little bit more focused on my terms I've
had being a king more of his political
side that's something that I know
chadwick boseman was emphasizing is that
he's a lot more of a politician because
he was at some point being told you get
to decide what kind of King you want to
be I feel like a lot of this will be
focusing on the type of decision-making
he'll have to do and the kind of leader
he has to learn how to beat since he is
now the king of Wakanda after the events
of what happened to his father in civil
war I do not have pronounce her name
it's the woman who plays Michonne and
not a spell it didn't deny Aggie era I
think that's how you say her name sorry
if I got it wrong I really like that you
got to see a lot more of her in this
trailer something tells me that she
might be somewhat of a scene stealer
because she's a pretty important
character in the black panther comics
I'm excited for her chemistry with
chadwick boseman because she seems like
she might have a little bit of a sense
of humor and I understand that this film
is probably gonna be a little bit more
on the serious side but there seems to
be a chemistry in heart that they were
teasing at in the trailer here between
her and she had way Bozeman T'Challa the
parts that really got me excited though
was Michael B Jordans era kill monger he
looks like he's gonna be a really really
damn good villain in terms of Michael B
Jordan performance he looks really
clever
he looks strategic and based off little
hints who were getting in the trailer I
get the impression that he's one of
those very philosophical types of
villains who will probably challenge to
chala and more than just fighting skills
but also mentality and point of views
although you see kill monger in his own
suit I'm kind of concerned you know if
it's gonna do that Iron Man
ant-man thing where you're like oh
there's evil black panther here now
we're like towards the end of the movie
he gets his suit it looks like it'll
come pretty early on considering kill
monger has a whole history with Wakanda
sometimes there's that cliche of the
villain in the origin movie having the
same power as the hero and sometimes
that works sometimes it doesn't I hope
it works here with an Andy Serkis you
know ulysses klaw with the sonic arm can
and i was so glad we got to see that
because we didn't get to see any of that
in age of ultron I don't recall seeing
any of that in the last trailer like
specifically him using a sonic arm
Cannon and that was really cool I'm
excited to see even more the effects
that that does cuz that's like the main
power with that character creating like
the sonic blast waves and and just the
images we got alone here I'm just hoping
with you know clogged kill monger both
being pretty important villains in the
Black Panther world that the movie does
a good job at balancing having both of
these guys here I hope it doesn't feel
like oh we should have just stuck with
one villain not the other obviously
they're working together they make that
clear in the trailer but I hope they
both get a chance to really shine
considering just how important they are
to fans of the Black Panther comics I'm
hoping I don't walk away with the movie
going they're both great actors and they
both do a good job I just wish that they
only stuck with one I feel like Ryan
Coogler would do a good job at being
able to handle two very important
villains in one movie but the more I see
at this movie the cooler it looks and I
like the type of music that they've been
putting over the trailers I hope they
use some of that music in the actual
film itself the one thing I would like
though too is to hear some like that
African tribal music because Rubicon
demand I want to hear some of that kind
of cool music too especially when you're
gonna explore the culture of Wakanda
alright guys what did you think of the
Black Panther trailer did you love it
that yeah I loved it I thought it was
really cool I'm pretty excited and
wasn't it damn infinity war trailer
coming you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow me at the Greg album on Instagram
and Twitter you can also follow us at
the stardust app that a lot of your
favorite youtubers are using download
the app Stardust and follow us at the
real rejects it check us out at patreon
patreon comm slash the real rejects good
day